translation API can be used to  dynamically translate a string into any  supported language let's see how to use  translation API with C sharp first make  sure the API is enabled in your project  and the service I can exist to make API  calls both are explained in the code lab  in the video notes in cloud shell let's  create a simple dotnet console app and  add translation API NuGet package to the  project  open the online code editor and navigate  to program Nazi s we will translate an  English text to Turkish reference to the  translation API library create  translation client specify the text to  translate and call translate text on the  text with to and from languages finally  printed translation  let's run the app there you go you just  translate the text using translation API